lots of questions about how
irrationality changes what we do so of
course we have demonstrations of people
being irrational from time to time and
the question is how big is the impact on
on ourselves and the answer is that it's
really very large there was this very
sad analysis that looked at the question
of what is the percentage of human
mortality that is either aided by or
caused by bad decisions right how often
do we make a bad decision that either
accelerates or kill us and when you look
at these results about 100 years ago you
say it's less than 10% think a hundred
years ago how could you make a bad
decision that would kill you not that
easy but you know you could do it from
time to time now it's more than 40% how
come what has changed
technology over time we've eventing
invented technology that can kill us so
of course texting and driving is very
clear
smoking diabesity OBD obesity some of
those are single mistakes that can kill
us like texting and driving but some of
those like obesity diabetes and smoking
are a series of mistakes that can kill
us and each of them is not as big but
together they accumulate and I think
that's actually what happens if you say
what is the percentage of the decisions
we make that are irrational I don't know
what the answer it's very hard to
compute but the fact is that those that
we make are incredibly dangerous
you don't have to text and drive that
many times to kill yourself you don't
have to start many habits in order to
accelerate your your death or to become
incredibly unhealthy so what happened is
that the world around us
is designed to tempt us you know one of
the principles from behavioral economics
is choice architecture the idea that we
when we are placed in the environment we
make decisions as a function of the
environment we're in think about the
environment that we're in what is it
about is it about our long-term health
or is it about the short-term profits of
that environment you walk down the
street there's a coffee shop what does
this coffee shop once they want you to
be healthy from in thirty years from now
or do you want them to do they want you
to buy another coffee
now Dunkin Donuts what is their
optimization function are they trying to
get you to be healthy in 20 years or to
buy another doughnut now your cell phone
what is it trying to do to get you to be
a productive citizen in two years or to
check your phone a couple of more times
today so what happened is that we are in
an environment that tempts us all the
time these temptations are only
increasing and because of that we fail
we fail we fail often because of that it
reduces dramatically our ability to do
some things like save and it will take
care of our health and therefore our
total well-being is going down
dramatically as well